there's a sort of infamous story about
you
in college
you were dating a big hillary supporter
so
my question i want to hear that story
but my question is what is a bigger
issue in a relationship politics
race
or religion i want to get everyone's
opinion on that
so tell your story and what do you think
is the biggest issue i've had a couple
of times where i've been on dates or
dated people who are not of the same
politics as me uh the first time that
you're talking about hillary clinton's
supporter was a girl who i dated and
we're getting into this whole argument i
think it was about like
muslims or people from north africa
coming into sweden and places and
and raping people and things like that
anyway we get into this whole argument
about it and i remember saying something
and she started crying she said you
sound like a trump supporter and i never
thought about that before and i was like
you know what maybe i am and then she
just cried harder and and that was the
end of that relationship or another girl
who i went on a date with here in la and
she asked me at the end the day she was
driving also by the way very progressive
of of me
and uh
picked me up went to griffith park and
some stuff and she asked me at the end
what i do for work and all this and told
her work in politics and conservative
politics told her who i voted for voted
for trump she starts crying i mean these
situations are just breaking hearts left
and right no we're not all the good
reasons exactly another time in a
karaoke bar a girl starts crying i mean
all the time i'm making girls cry
because
in boulder colorado nonetheless yeah
that one was actually in denver okay
denver is pretty much boulder these days
yeah um but i think the most important
thing is none of those things i think
it's values
values is the most important thing that
you guys need to have similar values
because even if you can have different
politics in people and disagree on some
political things yeah but again like we
talked about before politics isn't
values politics or something like tax
policy or you know what you should do
about immigration or something like that
but a lot of those things do connect to
values values is the most important
thing and if you guys share similar
values but differ on
all sorts of opinions i think that's
fine yeah you know what about you
fashion is it easier to date someone who
uh
or what's harder to do
different race different religion
different politics you're a democrat
he's republican ah it's not going to
work i'm jewish he's christian you know
black white what are you saying so um
the race thing
not really like a thing for me but like
more so um
religion religion can be a thing and
politics can definitely be a thing like
will said it it it's more about like
values like those things are definitely
values for me
um my religious views and um politics
it'll definitely if you're thinking
about long term with somebody those
things are very crucial to talk about
yeah cause how are you gonna raise your
children like what
how is that gonna go so that definitely
is a part of the values and taylor as a
conservative hippie
would you date a you know
liberal i don't know what's exactly do
it not yeah no and it's because straight
up
we wouldn't we wouldn't see eye to eye
and i like talking about those things i
like like about philosophy and like i
said it's not politics it's actually
philosophy and human nature that then is
how people decide their politics and
i wouldn't want to have i wouldn't want
we would be arguing i wouldn't want that
what do you think would be the biggest
argument in that relationship
oh god
depends uh as far as government control
taxes the way you raise your children um
how what are you going to teach them
what are you going to talk about
and
then the politics just stems from it i
can't give an exact answer because i
think
many things we wouldn't see eye to eye
on
would you date someone with a totally
different political perspective i know
you said you're libertarian so it's hard
but would you date someone who's like
super far left social justice warrior
blm antifa would you ever date someone
like that
i i wouldn't be able to so would you do
it why not i'm just kidding
it's gonna annoy the hell out of me
like just the like anything that i feel
like is super extremist annoys me yeah
like i feel like it's um it's smart to
be able to understand
um
different sides of everything anything
that's too extremist for me kind of gets
on my [ __ ] well as a beautiful black
woman
i'm sure i mean you get i when i
interviewed you hey mom what's up hey
you're like hey guys holler at you you
told me that sure so if a guy checked
off a lot of boxes successful making
money that's kind of like antithesis to
what it is um
but
he was like this super blm social
justice
uh you know wokester that just would be
a major turn off to you it would
definitely be a turn off for me um i
would i would try to i guess like if i
actually like this person and i want to
help them
i would try to like open their mind to
thinking you know about like not just
being so extremists of certain things i
would definitely try to talk to them
about that so if we could just to nail
this down of the three things i asked
politics race religion what is the least
important to most important of those
three race is the least yeah go ahead
what are your three races the least
politics wait religion politics
um
yeah politics religion so race is the
least important
politics politics and then religion is
the most a man that believes in god the
bible okay there it is how about you
fosh in that order okay um
let me think about that
so raise
okay so least important
to most important yes
least important
is race
politics and then religion okay well
i would say
same same but
one thing i just
so many people always talk about you
know it's fine to have these differences
and things like that or
all that i just don't get it this is
your life partner this is someone who
you're going to be married to discuss
everything with who's supposed to be
your supporter especially for me as
someone who works in politics and all of
this that person needs to be with me
they can have some small disagreements
and things and i can have small
disagreements with them but that person
needs to be on my team you know i don't
want someone who's not on my team and
also when it comes to raising children
you're going to raise my children
exactly with me you better teach my
children the right thing the thing that
i want them to know you know i want to
indoctrinate my children with my values
you know and people say oh you can't say
that i want my children to have good
values i'm going to instill that on them
and my partner needs to have the same
good things to put on them too so most
important is values and principles
[Music]